and then went back to went to Institute
for advanced studies for four-year
programming
biology I think all theoretical biology
General and you know at NC States doing
amazing stuff and I think he's recently
taken on
administrator role of an internal dean
of
academic Affairs or
it's also like that yeah so but it's a
great honor a great great honor to have
other Lloyd speak with us today on
special spread of dengue virus
appropriate spatial skills for modern
transmission Allen
so thank you very much Abba it's a real
pleasure to be here uh nice to get away
from well I guess my student issues
follow me around the world wherever I am
but um I I am always happy to help out
our students so I'm not going to
complain about that so I should mention
the beginning in case I run out of time
that this work
um you know many bits of this come from
long period of time uh I've been at NC
State for 20 years Fred Gould
um whose uh evolutionary ecologist in
the area around of Entomology showed up
in my office and in my second semester
on campus and got me interested in um
Dengue virus and the 80s egypti mosquito
that spreads it and so we've been
working together for the last 19 and a
half years and we've had a long
succession of of postdocs grad students
um who've worked on this project
so Dengue virus so um
ah
Dengue is a mosquito-borne disease and
it's the most important mosquito-borne
viral infection of humans so it's a long
way behind you know disease modelers
like to
Count Their importance by how many
deaths or cases their infection of
Interest relates to so you know Dengue
virus is a long way behind malaria in
terms of its death number of deaths it
causes but it causes a large burden of
disease
um Dengue virus is interesting I mean
not unlike covet there's a very wide
wide spectrum of outcomes from a large
number of people who are asymptomatic
through a um fairly mild uh some fairly
mild infections through to very severe
life-threatening outcomes that includes
Dengue hemorrhagic fever which involves
uncontrolled bleeding like this poor guy
here bleeding out of his eyes
um and if you have one of these very
severe forms the death rate can be quite
High there's no real treatment except
that you know you can basically
ameliorate it
um
and then an interesting thing about
Dengue that I'm not going to talk about
today is that there are four
immunologically
um distinct stereotypes of infections so
to a first approximation you can get
infected four times with each of those
four different stereotypes and something
that's caused a lot of interest for
modelers is that there's a very
complicated interaction via immunity
between those stereotypes so you can get
situations where having had one
stereotype before can give you a more
severe infection the next time
um and that's actually an important
point and one of the barriers
um that there's been to the development
of vaccines against Dengue because you
need to have a vaccine that works
against all four stereotypes or else
actually the vaccine can make matters
worse so you know there was a what do we
have we have the um
passed off uh past sanofi Pasteur
vaccine and that's only really indicated
for people who've already had a Dengue
infection the effectiveness of the
vaccine is different between people
who've had an infection before and not
which was bad news for vaccine
manufacturers because their target
Financial audience would be U.S tourists
going to for example southeast Asia but
you know typically we haven't
experienced Dengue so the vaccine would
not be indicated for those people
um at least generally there are no sort
of widely used antiviral drugs
and as I said the transmission of dengue
Dengue is a mosquito-borne infection and
to a first approximation it only goes
from mosquito to people and from people
back to mosquitoes so you have to have
this sort of two-step transmission cycle
um and the reason the Dengue is an issue
or the reason the mosquito-borne disease
is typically an issue is that female
mosquitoes need mammalian blood or blood
at least sorry to produce eggs so that
female mosquitoes bite and kind of just
a side effect of that is then you have
the potential for transmission between
humans and mosquitoes
um so again mosquito is typically
infectious forever once it gets
infectious until it dies
um and for for Dengue and indeed for
zika yellow fever and Chikungunya the
principal
um culprit is the 80s egypti mosquito
here and the fact that you can see this
big bulbous red bit at the back means
that mosquito has blood fed
um there is also a secondary Vector 80s
Alba picture that's a mosquito that we
have um quite a bit in the Southeast up
the Eastern Seaboard
um in the U.S
but it's much less effective at
transmitting Dengue and many of these
other viruses
the important thing to know about uh 80s
egypti is that they bite during the day
so for example you can't use bad Nets so
unlike malaria bednets are not going to
be an approach to combat Dengue these
mosquitoes are highly associated with
humans they lay their eggs in human
Associated water containers so here are
some photos taken out in the field in
Iquitos in Peru where we work with folks
from UC Davis who have had a long-term
study there you know people just have
I don't know maybe flower pots and
apparently toilets and things discarded
in their backyard they collect rain
water that's where mosquitoes lay their
eggs that's where the immature
mosquitoes um grow and develop and as I
said because we don't have vaccines or
antivirals the primary way of
controlling Dengue is by controlling the
number of mosquitoes and so that's
something I've worked on for a long time
but I'm not going to talk about the main
thing that I work on in that so I
actually work on um
development and deployment of
genetically engineered mosquitoes that
have been engineered to be resistant to
Dengue and that's usually what I talk
about but I won't talk about that today
so and we'll talk a fair bit about this
there's a fair uh there's a great deal
of complexity in the biology of the
mosquito the natural history of the
infection and the way that the
mosquitoes and people interact
and so this then always raises the
question of how complex a model um do
you need so this is what being one of
the themes of the research in our group
over the last 20 years is the
appropriate level of complexity and of
course this is a sort of standard
question in population modeling simple
or complex models so you know this sort
of debate goes back in in in population
ecology to the late 60s early 70s where
you know we all know the pros and cons
of going having simple models where we
can do math
but the real world is but they you know
neglect lots of reality and then you can
go all the way through to having
detailed individual based models the way
you typically can't do math and all you
can do is pretty mindless
TDS simulation
yes yes
so that's the yeah that's the other
problem with the more detailed models is
obviously the more complicated the model
the more parameters you have
um and so and and also you
well actually I guess all of these
models often our knowledge that biology
is no not
um as good as we would like so one of
the questions we always ask is if is a
given result robust across Frameworks
um if not why not so obviously the more
robust or more result is across a
spectrum of Frameworks the more
confidence we can have that it's a it's
a it's a genuine uh result and not just
an artifact of the model
um
on the other hand if we see some results
in one framework but not enough in
another that then tells us we should
probe what is the um what is the issue
that's causing that discrepancy and then
we can identify what the appropriate
level of complexity is
okay so I'm going to start off with the
simplest model from mosquito-borne
infection this one was originally
developed from malaria this is due to
Ronald Ross who won the Nobel Prize for
elucidating the transmission cycle of
malaria and that had included mosquitoes
so this model just has two equations
so we model humans as either being
susceptible or infected we model
mosquitoes as either being susceptible
and or infected and there's a key point
in these mosquito-borne disease models
the rate at which so transmission
depends on mosquitoes biting people
and so the rate at which mosquitoes bite
humans is always assumed to be
proportional to the number of mosquitoes
which makes sense the more mosquitoes
there are the more bites that'll happen
but independent of the number of people
so the assumption is that you know
mosquitoes need to bite because they
need to get blood
and that when a mosquito bite tries to
bite there's always enough people around
for them to find a blood meal
and so there's an asymmetry in
transmission terms in these sorts of
models transmission is proportional to
the numbers of susceptible or infected
mosquitoes but proportional to the
fractions of the human population that
are susceptible or infected
and of course this model like most
simple epidemiological models do does uh
exhibits threshold Behavior so we can
get Invasion and persistence in this
model if the basic reproduction number
is greater than one and of course that's
the average number of secondary
infections
um for a single infectious individual in
an otherwise susceptible population
and so here are the differential
equations so the the model further
assumes we have a constant number of
mosquitoes V for vectors and humans h
um and in this formulation at least in
the simplest model it ignores human
immunity but that's easy to
um relax that assumption and so these
are the two differential equations for
the Infectious humans and for the
Infectious mosquitoes
and just to sort of highlight a few
things that are going on here
so K is the biting rate the rate the per
mosquito rate at which they bite humans
p and Q are the transmission
probabilities
from mosquito to human and from Human to
mosquito
we have a recovery rate for humans we
assume they recover to a susceptible
State and we have a death rate from US
from mosquitoes
and again just to highlight the
transmission terms are proportional to
numbers of mosquitoes so either the
number of infectious mosquitoes I or the
number of susceptible susceptible
mosquitoes V minus I
but but proportional so the fraction of
the human population that is either
susceptible
or infections
so as I said this is asymmetry in the
transmission terms in this model
and once we have this model we can think
about the basic reproduction number but
we have to remember we have a two-step
life cycle so we go from a person to a
mosquito and then back to people
so really
uh I guess if Odo Dickman or Mick
Roberts were here they would they would
insist that really what I'm talking
about here is what they call the type
reproduction number so it's number of
secondary infections from a person back
to a person or from a mosquito back to a
mosquito and they're the same things so
I call those type reproduction numbers
um
well I I yes so
um so we have to multiply
the number of people infected by
infected mosquito by the number of
mosquitoes infected by an infected
person
that's okay
and in turn these sort of com so we have
two components the reproduction number
for the two halves of the life cycle and
for each of those components we just do
the standard thing and multiply
basically the transmission rate by the
amount of time that you're in the
Infectious state so from a mosquito to a
person we have to multiply the rate at
which that mosquito is biting the per
bite transmission transmission
probability and the average lifespan of
the mosquito
and then in the other direction we can
argue similarly by figuring out the rate
at which mosquitoes bite our focal
person and how long the person is
infected multiplying these two
quantities together we get the formula
down here for the basic reproduction
number two things to note here the
reproduction number involves the square
of the biting rate because one
transmission cycle involves two bytes
and and it involves the ratio of the
number of mosquitoes to the number of
people and that arises that enters
because of that asymmetry in the
transmission term
so this is the story from the simple
model so I guess back in the 50s and 60s
that's pretty much where the story ended
um because
the mosquito is just biting so when the
mosquito is in in is infected it's just
biting people so it's just giving rise
to infections at rate K times P but when
we have an infected person I have to
figure out at what rate is a mosquito
biting that infected person so I have to
take I have to take you know my infected
person is one over h
now that's the probability of the
mosquito bites someone so one out of my
age people are infected so that's where
the one over H comes from K because
we've got the mosquito biting rate and V
because there are V mosquitoes biting
okay so as we said before there's a lot
of complexity in the biology
and so there's lots of heterogeneity so
the question that has really been on
many of our minds is how important are
these heterogeneitys so both the
mosquito and the human populations but
also the interactions between the two
are highly structured and heterogeneous
so we can think about the human
population
um so here we have a map from Google
Google maps of the town in quitos in
Peru where we work or where the people
with whom we work work
um you know people this you know so
people live in houses in this city and
they move around between those different
locations and of course also not just
between houses between like houses and
workplaces houses and schools that sort
of thing
the mosquito population is spatially
distributed across the city one thing
you notice when you go out and do
surveys of mosquito numbers in people's
houses there's a high degree of
heterogeneity in the numbers of
mosquitoes found in different houses so
some people's houses have very few
mosquitoes other people have a whole
bunch of junk in their backyard lots of
places for the mosquitoes to lay their
eggs lots of mosquitoes as a result so
all of us the Assumption here that
everybody has a little backyard this is
in the car that's right that's that's a
sort of that's the sort of place uh as a
sort of location we're thinking of I
don't think I have a great picture of
that maybe there'll be something in a
minute maybe not we saw a bit of a
picture of those backyards earlier on
with those water water containments
and as I'll talk about in a minute
um the interaction between mosquitoes
and people and you probably know this
already but again we'll talk about this
some more mosquito bites are not
distributed uniformly across the human
population now highly heterogeneous
so some people and again I'll talk more
about this some people attract lots of
bites more likely to become infected
more likely to transmit so there's
potential for super spreading events and
we'll characterize this a bit in a
minute
so the question is how much does this
matter for the spread of dengue
so in this town of aquitos
um my collaborators have done a very
detailed study of how people move around
in this city so we're interested in the
spread of dengue across this city
um something I didn't tell you about a
guitar so it ketos is a town of about
300 000 people these days it's in the
middle of the Amazonian jungle so
basically this is one of the largest
places on Earth you can't get to by uh
by car from from another significant
population Center so really the only way
in or out here so it's like an
ecological Island the only way in or out
here is by plane or by boat up or down
the Amazon and so what my collaborators
did was they put GPS units on people and
watch them moving around the city and so
then they made you know probability
distributions of the probability of the
describing the movements that people
made
um also subdivide it into different you
can't really read it here but subdivided
into different age categories so you
could see that the kids move had
different movement patterns from adults
and from older people
um
um yes
absolutely I think I talked about
mosquito bites aren't uniformly
distributed across the human population
so another study that these guys did was
that they um
they looked at a number of houses and
the people who lived in those houses and
they looked at mosquitoes biting the
people in those houses so how do they do
this they
um would capture mosquitoes that had
bitten someone so the mosquito has that
sort of blood inside them and then they
do DNA fingerprinting on the blood from
the mosquito so then they can figure out
which person did that mosquito feed on
and so here they are looking at body
surface area so these are all the sort
of mosquitoes these are all the um these
are all I guess these are all the people
these are all the people in the survey
uh body surface area so a measure of
their size
the time spent in different houses so
they looked at a group of people and the
different places they went to so this is
a a 2d plot of the size of the person
and the amount of time that they spend
in the locations of interest and so you
know each of these dots here represents
a person being in a given location
and then the red dots here correspond to
when they found mosquito with that
person's blood so they could figure out
that a given person who was in a given
place got bitten by a mosquito
and so the key thing to see is that the
red dots are not distributed uniformly
across all of those dots so some people
tend to get bitten more often than
others and I don't know well I guess
there was a there was a news report on
this in the last week or so
um you know mosquitoes use various cues
to find people so they um you know they
know that the things they want to bite
exhale CO2 so they follow CO2 gradients
but they also follow other chemical cues
and so I mean I remember this as a kid
we used to go on vacation as a family
and my brother and I you know the
children would tend to not get bitten as
much as my parents now it's the other
way around so mosquitoes find it easier
to find bigger people because on average
you exhale more CO2 than smaller people
so larger people are more likely to get
bitten than
um smaller people but also as I say
chemical cues and I and I always
remember this that I can never remember
the way it works I remember once reading
an article that said there was a
difference in attractiveness to
mosquitoes depending on whether you
drank beer or wine and I can't remember
which which one was more attractive
[Laughter]
so you know this we have this hydrogen
we have all these heterogeneity
and if you eat garlics and they don't
come to you right
so there is there is some garlic story
as well which I can't remember but
um yeah
that's not blood group right there's all
there's also there's all sorts there's
all sorts of things it's very
complicated
um
but here's an example another one of
these sorts of studies where they um did
DNA profiling of blood got from
mosquitoes in Puerto Rico where there
were about 100 residents who they
identified as being
um
um connected to these houses
and they found that of all the blood
they recovered from mosquitoes three
people accounted for 56 percent of those
blood meals so it's clear you know
mosquito bites are highly concentrated
on a on us on a small group of people
and so there's clear potential here for
super spreading
and of course you know we just know that
um that then has important implications
for control
um and the uh relative effectiveness of
random control versus targeted control
so our standard tool in this area for
exploring the impact of heterogeneity is
the multi-type model where we basically
take the Ross model and we just
subdivide we just have different types
of individuals so we subdivide our
compartments According to some one or
more
um
feature so we could have a collection of
different attractivenesses of people we
could have spatial locations
and so then we have indices on the
mosquito on the on the human population
and the mosquito population
and now rather than having single
transmission parameters or transmission
probabilities we have a matrix of
transmission probabilities in fact we
have two of them because we have the
mosquito the human and the human to
mosquito
um and so one one example here would be
the the index might represent different
spatial locations so then these
transmission parameters would would
depend on the fractions of time spent in
different locations so that would be a
um lagrangian formulation where we're
sort of modeling movement implicitly
saying that um you know an individual
spends a certain fraction of their time
in one location another location and so
on
so this is sort of very classical
epidemiological framework except we've
got this two type
um process
so we know exactly what to do to find
things like the basic reproduction
number here we do the standard Next
Generation approach
and we make the Next Generation Matrix
where we a matrix of the number of
secondary infections of type I caused by
an individual of type J and then we have
to find the dominant eigenvalue of that
Matrix
now in general of course that's
something you know for a general Matrix
that's not going to be possible but if
we make simplifying assumptions
um we can find explicit forms for basic
reproduction number when we have certain
types of mixing for instance when the
next Generation Matrix is of rank one
so one example of this and this one goes
back to Chris dye from the 1980s is a
preferential biting model uh where where
mosquitoes allocate bytes according to
different fractions on different types
of hosts
and it turns out you get a rank one next
Generation Matrix so you can write down
the basic reproduction number and then
you can do some manipulation and put it
in this form where we get what we see
what we have is the product of the
reproduction number if we had a
homogeneous well-mixed system multiplied
by an inflating factor which is one plus
the variance of these biting fractions
so in this case heterogeneity inflates
the reproduction number compared to the
homogeneous setting so this is a
standard result that we know from
spread of sexually transmitted
infections it's exactly analogous to
that ABBA you had a question yeah do we
need a square root before they are not
just show the two generations or well
there's a reason I don't despair root
right because I work with the type
pre-production number right so for me
you know so the difference between the
Arnold and the square root and not is
what you consider a generation to be so
for me a generation is a complete life
cycle whereas in square root formulation
the generation is one transmission step
so so Alan I just don't like having to
put square roots around stuff so I'm
happy to work with the
gamma
a random quantity what's the variance so
popular computers
um
well so so it could it could just be
that you've specified a collection of
numbers and you just work it so you you
know you've got like
um a half a quarter and a quarter and
you just work out the variance of those
numbers it I mean it just comes from a
it just comes from the fact that here
we've got a uh a sum over of squared
quantities it's just a manipulation of
the formula for the variance
okay so so variants so you don't mean
that every one of these Gammas is is a
random quantity basically so in this
case I've got like you know a certain N
I got a number n or in this case M
groups
and I've got a collection of Gammas that
add up to one so it's like the
fractional well maybe they don't even
have to be normalized here I forget
um you've just got a collection of these
numbers
so and you just work out the variance
across them
yeah I mean so the results from the
previous slide is this oops sorry
there's a special case of a sort of a
general result from this sort of model
in mathematical epidemiology so
um these rank one matrices come from
what we call separable transmission and
so the general result is that we have a
vector saying talking about the
susceptibilities of individuals of
different groups and the infectiousness
of different groups so here I call that
the A and the B
and in general then in this set sort of
setup the reproduction number is given
by the reproduction number under the
average multiplied by a factor one plus
the correlation between the um
susceptibilities and the
infectiousnesses multiplied by the
coefficient of variation of the
susceptibilities and the coefficient of
variation of the infectiousnesses and
the previous result is a special case
when infactivity and susceptibility are
perfectly correlated that correlation
coefficient is one and the square the
coefficient of variation equals variance
over the mean so I'm missing some
largest some spectral radius here so
don't you have if you have this multi
types which you have here the
the spectral radius of some Matrix for R
naught typically yes but I'm saying I
mean I'm in a special case so in this
case it's it's a matrix diagonal maybe
it's a I I would the the yes I work out
R naught by just summing the entries on
the diagonal of the Matrix yeah
Sigma AI so you've got a matrix what is
it it's like uh
that entries The Matrix are
are like a i b j
so it's separable and so the um the
dominant eigenvalue is a i b i and I've
maybe done something sneaky where I've
divided by n because I don't care about
the number of groups that are or
something like that
so anyway this is oh and so the point is
here that that when we have
heterogeneity
in in the sort of simple case like it's
actually transmitted infections or the
biting preference because the
heterogeneity impacts both your chance
of acquiring infection and transmitting
infection
um the coefficient of the uh correlation
coefficient is one and heterogeneity
always increases our naught but in
general
um you know those two things need not be
positively correlated and it could be
that heterogeneity actually decreases R
naught but in our case at least the um
the high degree of heterogeneity in
biting preference means this coefficient
of variation squared is much larger than
one and so
this term
often dominates this term and so uh the
the r naught expression you get if you
ignored the heterogeneity can be a
severe underestimate this is exactly the
same as in sexually transmitted
infections
I'll just mention that you can extend
this sort of analysis to think about
more than two heterogeneities
and things get a lot more complicated
when you have more than two coupled
heterogeneities
so in fact you can even have
heterogeneity having a non-monotonic
impact on Arnold which is quite curious
okay so I'm going to I'm going to now
think more about human movement so the
problem of people moving around the city
and transmitting Dengue
and one thing you should know about
aedes aegypti is that they are rather
lazy compared to say malaria mosquitoes
Hades aegypti are rather lazy mosquitoes
they tend not to move very much
um particularly they don't move much
compared to people so if an 80s egypti
mosquito finds itself in a place where
there's water for it to lay its eggs
there are people to bite they maybe
don't move much more than 100 meters
over the course of their lifetime
so to a first approximation Dengue is
going to be moved around a city mainly
by people
so I often will simplify things by
ignoring movement of mosquitoes and just
focus on human movement
as I've said there are lots of people
out there who use individual based
models to look at this sort of question
um
and it's highly computation intensive so
there are models out there for a ketos
where they will model the movement of
each of those 300 000 people around the
city and you know simulate the spread of
epidemics that result
I prefer most the time to stick with
more mathematically
defensible and grounded models and we
could adopt that lagrangian model which
I mentioned earlier and there's actually
a really nice series of papers by
bishara Airtel that do this
um actually and as I'll mentioned a bit
I guess actually explicitly work out our
naught expressions
but particularly when I'm thinking about
stochastic models where I'm thinking
about individuals moving discreetly and
move and they're actually being movement
events from one place to another I
prefer a model where we actually move
individuals explicitly between patches
so
um okay and also now because I really am
thinking about Dengue and not malaria I
am going to use
um an s i r model for people so people
will recover to a recovered and immune
state
and then I also have demography so I
have births of new of new susceptible
individuals I also have deaths from each
of the classes
so this would be my model in a single
patch
and now I'm going to add on terms that
describe the movement of people so for
each differential equation I'm going to
add on a term that describes the
departure of um individuals of that
compartment from our patch and the
arrival of individuals of that type from
all the other patches so I've got this
Matrix here then of pijs that talk about
the movement between of individuals
between patches and of course I need to
have a conservation uh rule on that so
all the individuals that leave a patch
have to arrive somewhere
oh that's right and also this simplest
model is memoryless so it doesn't
remember the patch from which
individuals came so they moved from
patch one to patch two and then when
they're in patch two they move to other
patches they don't remember that they
came from patch one that's not a
desperately good model for how people
are going to move from their homes to
different locations around the city so I
can make a more realistic model which I
wouldn't really care to write down
but a more realistic model that tracks
people's home patches so when they move
from patch one to patch two you remember
that these individuals from patch one
and so when they leave patch two we send
them back to patch one so that's like a
horrendous bookkeeping exercise because
you have to you know you multiply the
number of states by the number of
patches that you have to remember
so as I said for this sort of model you
can do the next uh you can calculate
basic reproduction numbers you can use
the Next Generation Matrix approach
um
so I don't have a workplace and a home
place no I mean in in the in the model
that I've looked at no they will just
visit other Patches at random with some
set of probabilities and then they'll go
back
um I mean I guess those
that's right so you don't have the same
individuals
um going to the same places so you don't
have like the repeated movement that
would probably be that would for sure
actually be real uh what really happens
in the real world so it's a lagrangea
not hilarious right you you well no it's
eulerian in that I'm actually move I'm
moving people from patch to patch
but I don't remember I so I'm I mean the
the eulerian is the fact that I'm I'm
actually moving people between patches
right so I'm not implicitly modeling the
fraction of time spent in different
patches but they do not go back to their
original patch well like migration now
that we modeling Michael they move to
another patch and stay there right in
this model they move to another patch
and then they forget that they've ever
been in a in their things reset but in
this model we keep track of where they
came from so what we don't keep track of
here I mean so the next step then is the
fact that people have habitual movements
so not only do they return to the same
patch but they would also have a
tendency to move to similar patches when
they move excellent so a person going to
and from work
so of course all that's really easy to
do in an individual based model right
so as I said uh you can do the analysis
and bachara atal did this analysis they
got explicit generations for Next
Generation matrices they got explicit
formulas for R naught in certain special
cases
um
basically where you have a whole bunch
of symmetry so that essentially all
patches are equivalent
and one thing I didn't tell you here
well I guess you know the implicit
question is how much does human movement
impact our naught
and
if you do this analysis and you're in a
sort of a homogeneous symmetric case
what you find is that human movement
does not impact our Lord
that result was rather
disappointing to me but not surprising
because of course if you have a
homogeneous symmetric situation all the
patches are equivalent so it doesn't
matter if you're individuals in patch
one or patch two or patch three they're
giving rise to secondary infections of
the same rate regardless of where they
are so it doesn't matter about them
moving around
Mobility between parties is linear race
or is dependent on the disease activity
and I actually share this question wow
my tendency to go to patch B it depends
on how many times
so what about mosquito movement are the
mosquitoes sort of uniform so so
remember my big simplifying assumption
here I know because it's 80s egypti I
ignore mosquito movement so I'm thinking
just about you know because the
mosquitoes are moving maybe from one
house to the next maybe two houses
around that isn't going to transmit
Dengue across the city so the first
approximation
um uh the movement of dengue across the
city is due to people moving not due to
humans
foreign
sorry yeah so if and and people and
movement is nothing I mean disease and
movements are completely unrelated I
don't even in this in this simplest
model you know maybe because most people
who have Dengue it's mild or even
asymptomatic having infection doesn't
stop you from moving going to another
okay
doesn't change sorry mosquito abundance
in the simplest model no it doesn't
change okay just just for the records I
asked about the mosquitoes
so again simplest model I assume we have
a constant number of mosquitoes
um per patch equally everywhere uh in
the same in a simple setting yes of
course so I should say of course you
know if you have heterogeneity
then human we would will impact
downl's results show that but in the
simplest case where everything is
um you know everything is is homogeneous
movement doesn't impact our Lord
but the interesting thing is if you set
up individual based models
um even under my sort of very
restrictive uh conditions of homogeneity
simulation-based results from those
individual based models clearly show
that human movement impacts the ability
of the infection to spread and if I did
a Markov chain formulation of the
multi-patch model I would also get
um
similar results so we have conflicting
results between what you see from the
simulation models and that are naught
analysis
okay so I take my differential equations
and I reinterpret all those processes as
um
as in terms of Markov chain so I have
you know a rated which individuals
become infectious I have a rate to which
individuals recover
so it's just the standard correspondence
between a an equivalent I mean you have
100 so
you have a hundred thousand people that
should be the law of large numbers why
are they different okay we'll come on to
that in a minute
so that's the point that that is this is
exactly the point so
um I set up a Markov chain model that's
cut that corresponds to my set of
differential equations in in that um way
and what I consider is a human
population of 20 000 people small
because of simulation modest because the
simulations are expensive I consider
different Arrangements of patches
different patch configurations
so I go from having five patches of size
four thousand so I'm thinking of
modeling the city at the level of what
they call like their health districts so
I have a small number of large patches
down to 4 000 patches of size five so
I'm thinking of houses so I'm thinking
about a large number of small houses
and so that's what the different colors
on this graph represent our simulation
results under different patch
configurations
so over here
we have a small number of large patches
coming across to a large number of small
patches
so this thing here is is considering
houses
this thing here is basically just
considering areas of the city
and we have some measure of the ability
of the infection to spread so in this
case it's outbreak size
in terms of the per individual
probability of moving from one location
to another per day
so sorry yeah I would expect that
outbreak size does depend because if you
move you sort of effectively get more
susceptible vertices at your disposal
but I would so outbreak sizes are not
don't necessarily have to go hand in
hand
um that is true I just happen to have
shown this set of results I also have a
graph maybe it's in these slides I don't
think it is in these slides where I
basically show transmission parameter
and outbreak size you can see where the
threshold Behavior happens and you see
similarly the threshold happens the
different values of the transmission
parameter
so it's and so remember the the sort of
differential the r naught the r naught
sort of analysis would tell us that the
movement parameter doesn't actually
matter
um
but you know here we see the movement
parameter does matter
and so what's going on the Arnold type
analyzes it's always your initial
Behavior
right so you assume a fully susceptible
population so it's basically linearizing
transmission
so essentially you always set this
number of susceptibles equal to the
patch size
and the point is for Dengue when we're
thinking about transmission on the scale
of the city
there's this appropriate spatial scale
the house is the appropriate spatial
scale on which mixing happens so the ha
the house is the natural scale at which
to model things and we simply always
have small numbers of individuals on
that scale so a house has two three five
ten people a house doesn't have a
thousand ten thousand people
so the point is what goes on in this in
this setup is that basically
transmission gets to a infection gets to
a house you get spread within the house
and then you get spread to the next
house so you have that intrinsic spatial
scale of a house that is sort of
irreducible and not not in a
mathematical sense but there's that
irreducible biological component of
transmission
and so this sort of Dynamics can are
never going to be captured by that sort
of deterministic
um our naught type analysis even though
we can set patch sizes to be small
I mean those deterministic models simply
don't respect the fact that individuals
are discrete and so you know in a house
of size five loss of one susceptible has
has a pretty large impact on
transmission in that house
so for me who has spent a large chunk of
my career since my PhD basically
analyzing these deterministic
multi-patch models this was really
unfortunate because it means that my
standard go-to analytic tool is much
less useful than we would hope when
we're understanding transmission of
dengue at the within City scale so of
course this is an important thing to
know because there are all these papers
out there in the literature that the
claim you can use these models for that
but I I am not convinced of their
utility
so
this then this then put me in a rather
not desperate uh and a rather
pessimistic situation that these people
who do these large-scale individual
based models really were were the
winners in this story so to speak
um and I wasn't entirely happy to uh
concede that fact so I think you know
the the The Plea or The Plea at the time
was the point I wouldn't concede because
I would think that if you
you just can't Analyze This Thing by
looking at sort of Time Zero so you have
to run your differential equation long
enough that you see the depletion within
the patches
and then this should actually start to
I'm not see I'm not sure so or for
example if you look at final outbreak
size I don't think you'd get that I
don't think you would get the
distinction because the point is in the
deterministic model a fraction
an ATO human can move an ato-infected
human can move from one patch to the
next seed infection there
so I I am not and then it would burn
through that patch but then again you'd
get it you get very small transmission
to somewhere else and it would burn
through I
I actually had thought that I really do
need to put in the corresponding
determinist results and I think we would
be disappointed we would be similarly
disappointed if we actually looked at
final outbreak size of the deterministic
model
you don't think you could model that by
having different time scales it's sort
of your
because if you're if you're if your
infection would sort of run out in your
patch faster than your movements then
you should I just I don't think that's
gonna I don't think that happens in a
deterministic model because as I say
small fractions of individuals can go
from one patch to another
and then once it gets there your local
Arnold is greater than one so it's going
to spread it'll take longer
but it's going to spread so in a sense
you're in the random environment do you
you have this stochastic effect at the
level of yours exactly that's exactly
the point we can't appeal it's exactly
because the house is the appropriate
unit in which to model things we can't
we can't appeal to a law of large
numbers here right
so that that would be very intuitive
Alan don't you think I mean once you've
figured out that that's the yeah sort of
level of yes yes yes okay but then of
course the question is what do we do
and so then
um you know so there is a tool that
people use to look at spread of
infection where you have a household a
population that's structured in terms of
households and these so-called
households models that go back to the um
60s and 70s that have been really
successful in the uh directly
transmitted um infection world so have
have been used heavily in um modeling
spread of flu and common colds and so on
but these models had never before
um existed in the vector-borne disease
literature
and so some collaborators of mine in
Australia are Josh Ross and Andrew black
um came up or extended these households
models to mosquito-borne diseases and so
these models are formulated at the level
of households and looks at the spread of
households and and as part of that you
have to have a model of the within
household spread of infection
and in this world of households models
uh the users concede that the are not
formulated at the individual scale is no
longer the appropriate
um quantity to look at in terms of a
transmission threshold but they have
something called R star which is R
naught basically evaluated the household
size at the household scale so you use
the household as the um the unit on
which you're looking at transmission so
we have a paper that's currently under
revision that's up on the archive and
I'll just give a brief flavor of it
um basically it's a branching process
model it makes a whole bunch of
assumptions at least in the very first
formulation of it but most of these can
be relaxed we assume again that people
move mosquitoes don't introduction into
households is relatively rare so we only
have to think about
single introductions rather than
multiple introductions we consider a
collection of households at the moment
of households of the same size Each of
which has n people and M mosquitoes we
can relax those assumptions
and so then in this framework you have
two sorts of infected household
characterized by how infection was
introduced
and so either I'm a susceptible person
from your household has gone somewhere
else and been bitten by an infectious
mosquito or an infected person from
elsewhere has visited your house so as I
say we have two sorts of infected
household and then use a two-type
branching process that describes
transmission and looks at you know the
number of houses of each type that are
caused by a house of a given time
and then this this approach implicitly
involves looking at the um uh the final
size distributions uh within the two
sorts of household
I think of the households yes
so n is large but the number of people
in the hospital
in this case we have a large number of
households all of which have the same
number of people and the same number of
mosquitoes yeah in in this very simple
version of the model people
doesn't countries that's right we have
we always have a finite and you know
small population size at the household
level but finite number of small number
of people and a small number of
extensions yeah and should I think of
the household I have a household and a
bipartite graph with all the mosquitoes
or it's no no so so remember for us
mosquitoes don't move so basically we
have mosquitoes staying in a household
so we just have a collection of
households and we have movement of
people between the different households
but you do not really model
that a person gets bitten mosquitoes
that still has this thing on us yeah at
the level of a household yes
correct sorry sorry I thought you told
me that the between households yes
but your model has sort of
but as I say these things can be these
things these assumptions can be relaxed
so we can have a distribution of human
household sizes and distribution of
mosquito
um numbers for different houses as well
but we haven't done that yet but that
that's a that's a fairly simple
um generalization I mean at least that
generalization has been made in the
directly transmitted household the model
and it's not all that much extra
complication
okay so that's me finished uh so as I
say simple models can give us important
insights but it's really important for
us to understand the limitations
um so heterogeneity can be really
important and we can at least imagine
that we can use those simple models to
give insight into the importance of
heterogeneities but we have we run up
against this issue of spatial scale of
transmission that limits the utility of
this those the sort of standard go-to
analytic tool
um as I said individual based models
have their devotees but these models
aren't the most uh satisfying to use uh
and I think this households model
um is a pretty promising new analytic
tool and we're hoping it's going to be
able to provide um new insights into for
example the role of human movement on
the spread of dengue
and so just finishing up with the
acknowledgments
um as I said a whole bunch of people at
NC State
um the mosquito folks
um generally at UC Davis and at Emory we
were part of a a large NIH project Grant
uh that was looking at
um impact of disease and move on
actually it is at impact of disease on
movement and on transmission
and then the folks at Adelaide and
various people who funded this over the
years and that's me done excellent okay
thank you for a fantastic talk uh any
questions see us sorry
very interesting talk one one thing that
in mosquito many articles Dengue Factor
plays is environmental viability the
generation time of the mosquitoes are
tightly related to temperature
precipitation Radiance right I don't
know the layout of Iquitos but yeah
assume that there are mountains or
mountain ranges nearby or something like
that so this create different uh
altitude gradients right that even
though you're much model could be very
simple and homogeneous in terms of the
structure of the model the conditions
for transmission in the different
Patches at different altitudes or
different regimes of precipitation
temperature
May alter
that homogeneity and give you a correct
result even for a simple framework that
you have so have you considered this
climate variability well okay so I mean
what I didn't show you was the full
horror so we have even though I said
most of my time saying about Dreadful
Things We have basically an individual
based mosquito model that actually looks
at it's just horrendous it I I even
sketch it was thinking about it that
actually we have a resource temperature
weather driven mosquito models so we
actually look because in in the in my in
the main project which is on the spread
of these genes through mosquito
population we really care about the
population Dynamics and genetics of
mosquito across space
um so yes we we have a model that looks
at that actually in the ketos it's
fairly homogeneous across the city
um and actually because it's um yeah
pretty equatorial it's not there's not
so much variation across the year as for
example when we when we try to model
this in Australia where it's highly
seasonal
um and of course the other thing which
you well know is that it's not just the
mosquito that's impacted by temperature
and and so on it's then the virus within
the mosquito so the that's a really
important thing that um the amount of
time it takes the virus to incubate
within the mosquito varies is highly
sensitive to temperature which is one of
the concerns about global warming that
whose vector-borne diseases not only
will the mosquitoes you know find
themselves Elsewhere on the planet but
the transmission cycle will shorten
because you know it takes five days or
four days rather than seven days
um for the virus to incubate inside the
mosquito thank you
thank you for a nice talk um I'm
interested I was interested in your
discussion of heterogeneity about how
you decoupled the susceptibility and the
infectiousness
I'm used to thinking of those things as
being correlated basically to do with
numbers of contacts right
um uh so that your CVA and your CVB
would be basically the same thing right
um What What In this disease or
generally in other infections what is it
that causes those to become separate is
it within the host effects or is it is
it effects of the contact patterns or
the movement right so as you say if if
the heterogeneity is is a sort of a
contact heterogeneity typically the
susceptibility and infectiousness will
be proportional to each other that
correlation is one but it could be
I'm trying to think of examples it could
be like
um
it could be like biting heterogeneity
would be the same as that because
mosquitoes you know it's more like
transmission it impacts Transmission in
both directions but people also think
about other things you know there could
be just differences in infectiousness
across the human population and that
then wouldn't be correlated with the
propensity of the of the mosquito to
bite the people for instance viral
within a spiral load within within host
viral load something like that yeah a
duration of infection something else
that people have thought about as being
heterogeneous across the population so
there's all sorts of factors so you know
depending on which factors you're
thinking about they would not
necessarily be any need for them to be
positively correlated
um we actually have we have a paper sort
of setting out that I mean obviously
that slide that slide or two was very
sort of theoretical and obviously not
directly related to the rest of them in
terms of the grounding in in biology
um we have a sort of a theoretical paper
that lays out this sort of multiple
heterogeneity framework and we had spent
a whole day sort of talking about
different heterogeneities and whether
they might be positively or negative
with correlated or not correlated at all
I think there are some comments on that
in that paper
so it entirely depends what what facets
we're thinking of in terms of
transmission
well thank you very much for your for
your talk so I have a question so at
first you were mentioning the fact that
there were four cell types and and then
does that appear anymore so yeah so can
we have this kind of of feature also
including the model or yeah you can
um you know obviously if you have four
stereotypes you have to at the very
least multiply you know each of our
infectious compartments by you know used
to have four times as many infectious
compartments to track the um you know
the different infections
then you also have to track people in
humans they're together to be infected
twice by the Same by the same but you
can be infected twice about different
things so what you also have to track
unfortunately is people's infection
history
so if you track everything you know so
I've had and maybe even the order in
which you've had your infections could
be important so
um you know if you do the four full four
serotype model your number of states or
number of equations
um increases dramatically there are some
simplifications so one of them is that
you only remember your body only
remembers your previous infection
so but then of course you wouldn't get
permanent immunity to a given stereotype
so uh basically it's uh
again really easy to do in an individual
based model makes the differential
equation models really complicated again
it's only I mean it complicated in it's
just bookkeeping so it's not sort of
conceptually difficult it's just
practically difficult
um
and so yeah I just take the coward's way
out and I think about imagine we've got
a population where there's only one
stereotype of dengue circulating so I
can think about just one seroton
can we do also a comment so it seems
that you are many times opposing like um
uh deterministic dynamical systems and
individual based models but individual
based models are not only like
simulations you can have as we as agent
for instance showed in the first day or
as Greg has done so you can have a
stochastic processes this really
mathematically describing individual
base model and that allows you to also
to link uh between like uh branching
processes approximations uh dynamical
systems so I would not see everything
like so opposed but well well I mean I
mean right so service is my career right
and my you know my I I mean I go back a
long way and I you know started off
doing deterministic things and then I do
stochastic things so I have a lot of
papers on their correspondence between
the the deterministic and stochastic
models
um and it's a tool that I use in lots of
settings but I'm just saying in this
particular case where the household is
the most important scale on which
transmission happens
we are in a rather difficult place I
mean then of course then of course I
moved to a looking at things on the
scale of households and then I use a
branching process model so I mean it's
all good in the end but I'm just saying
that we need to you know be mindful that
we can't just take it we can't just take
standard deterministic tool and I you
know and and it might be completely
obvious in retrospect that we can't do
this but this doesn't stop the fact that
there have been tens of papers at least
in the literature doing doing precisely
that in very recent years so
um you know it's one of these things
it's really not to say no completely
completely yeah so
I mean when people model every single
person in the city I would call that
agent right but when you do your
stochastic households yes that is this
is this is just that is Monte Carlo
Monte Carlo simulation it's also
actually do give us insights so I mean
well I mean I get clear inside here in
the fact that the um scale in which I
model things has a Major Impact yes
Associates
but sometimes I understand that you
cannot do like averaging inside the
household because it's very small yeah
but if you have a lot of households so
even if you have a stochastic Behavior
like in small household they can average
if if your unit is a household not the
not the individuals then well that's
exactly yeah so I mean that's exactly
the point right the households model is
formulated at the the unit in the
households model is the household
but the determinant but the sort of
standard deterministic thing just has
patches
and you know
it has no notion of the fact that
there's something special about a patch
of size five or ten that's the point so
it no but in the deterministic model I
would almost think of the household
as so if the household has four people I
think of it as a unit which has two to
the four states depending who is in fact
or maybe three to the four states
and then you can describe a differential
equation this describes how this more
complicated individual which now has
more internal States
interacts and maybe it's not a
differential equation that right I mean
I mean
of course ultimately I can just write
down the column of equation for the
whole the whole thing right but that's a
ginormous system
no no I don't want you to do that I want
to but I'm glad you don't want me to do
that no I want to think so I want you to
think of the household if it really only
has four people yeah as something which
has sort of two to the four states or so
just and there's sort of some okay in
reality it's not just exponential times
and stuff but maybe you can approximate
it inside sort of you describe it now as
transitions inside this
but it's its own state so I don't want
you to think of the household as a
Continuum in your
in your differential equation but then
you have sort of now you place each
house that becomes a new individual in
your differential equation model except
that each individual now has more states
to take into account the richness of the
household
I mean I mean I think I think this is I
think this is not unlike what we're
doing in the households model to be
honest
but that would again give you a
differential equation if you like them
so much or maybe integral equations well
here well here we're really I mean in
the households model we have a branching
process because we're thinking about
Invasion right so is it going to go from
this household to the next household and
so on
but yes they could there could well be a
differential equation I guess there for
um
households
you you were not here a couple days ago
but we basically talked about this sort
of markovian models with the with
Frailty or precisely with the type of
heterogeneity of susceptibility and
infectiousness and we discussed briefly
how these can be decoupled sort of in a
canonical way
and it kind of seems like that might be
a strategy I think that's what Tran is
saying and what what Christian is saying
is kind of maybe the the the the part of
the discussion that we had
so you know if you were to formulate the
Markov model at the level of a house
called yeah and you somehow could
incorporate in in a sensible way these
heterogeneity I think that's exactly
what happens
that's what I'm trying to say I think I
think we are we are saying this I think
what I'm trying to say is I don't think
there's anything new here because I
think that's precisely what was done
back in the 70s in these households
models
but you can basically just just look at
the markup process right which is a
household level markup process and for
that process you will have some kind of
law of large numbers that would take
into account the the frame across
household right right right right right
yeah but that's yeah yes
some rather than doing the branching
process between households you do the
law of large numbers between households
but obviously the five is not a law of
large numbers so you have to keep the
five discrete and you will pay for that
by having a higher dimensional State
space yes but you still should be able
to do a law of large numbers well I
could not have to do a branching process
for the spread between households well
except something if except like if I'm
thinking about initial spread right
whether it's stochastic you want to
understand the stop has testing sure
yeah I mean like whenever we think about
invasion of infection into a population
you know Invasion starts off with one
individual you know one household so
then we you know
yeah so you know there's this colleague
of mine
who basically looks at household studies
and who believes that the entire
epidemiology is about households so he
would love your talk and I think that
it's a shame Tom isn't here because you
know Charles Thomas work that's connects
to that as well that's true yeah so yeah
so much fun I like this but I'll ask a
question
so for Dengue okay the Aries mosquitoes
provide back during the day so and I
would assume that people tend to spend
more time Outdoors than indoors right
what's the average time I spend at home
for example in the morning it's not all
so the transmission is really taking
place out doors isn't it
so so I'm playing Devil's Advocate you
know it's all about households
households so of course
oh it's different yeah it's different
it's different so I think I think most I
mean the feeling there is that most the
transmission is happening in indoors so
people stay at home most of the time
during the day right people are inside
yeah yeah let's see let's see well and
the mosquitoes tend to be inside because
that's where the people are so you know
these mosquitoes tend to bite like
um you know maybe Also earlier in the
day and later in the afternoon so I
think so it's it's when people are
around I mean maybe that's when I invite
at that time and the problem with the
Dengue mosquitoes it doesn't I don't
like malaria mosquito it doesn't need a
lot of water to lay eggs right so this
is just very easy to get rid of habitats
yeah that's very good okay any other
question I think we should let Alan go
this is fantastic presentation a very
nice discussion of course thank you so
much Alan for very nice presentation
thank you okay
all right uh it's lunch time now I
believe yes yes bye